Hey what's up guys?! It's Rob. I hope
you're all doing well. I've been learning
how to do some different things lately
learning some animation though I'm not
really good at it, but maybe if I
practice enough I'll get better since
it's always something I wanted to try. It
was also my cat Leela's 12th birthday
last week on April 19th and I posted
some pictures and videos on my Instagram
IG: TheRobWorld so be sure to check that
out I'll post a link down below. I've
always wanted to do a juggling tutorial
'cuz I think it's something that everyone
should really know how to do. It also
seems about 80% of people on my
community poll want to see it also. The
definition of juggling that I've always
remembered is the manipulation of more
objects than you have hands: so two or
more objects in one hand or three or
more objects in two hands. Juggling is
not only fun and entertaining but it's
extremely good for your hand-eye
coordination and reflexes and also your
left and right brain balance. For this
tutorial I'm going to teach you how to
do the Cascade which basically involves
the balls going in a figure eight motion
there is a way to do it that they go in
a circle but I'll leave that for another
time.
Juggling is something that you do need
to practice to get good at. It might take
you a couple hours, days, it depends on
you and how much you put into it.  Optimally,
we want to start with some bean bag balls
just like these I do offer these on my
Amazon Store that you can find in the
links down below.  Using really bouncy
balls like hand balls and tennis balls
aren't really the best to start with but
if you really have nothing and you want
to try it out you can also take a wet or
dry paper towel and wrap it in aluminum
foil like this. So guys.. What do you say?
Want to learn how to juggle? Let's do it!
I learned how to juggle for my brother
Rick over 15 years ago and when I got to
college someone tossed me two Ketchup
packets at the same time and when I
caught them they said "How'd you do that?"
and I said "cuz I juggle" #CuzIJuggle
Making sure our feet are shoulder-width
apart and our hands a little bit above
our waist with our palms up, we're going
to imagine a window frame in front of us
Our eyes are looking at the top of that
frame a little bit above our head, right
around where the ball will hit its Apex
or Peak. When we throw, we're going to
keep the balls within that plane and its
boundaries and our eyes at the top of
the frame we need to therefore develop
the ability to catch the ball by sort of
predicting where it will land and not
looking directly at it. I'm left-handed
and start with the ball in my left hand
and throw it to my right but you might
prefer starting with your right hand.
We're trying to toss it between our
hands in an arc as precisely and
consistently as possible. Remember we
need to say within the plane and
dimensions of the window frame so we
don't throw the ball too far back or
forward or move our feet. We also don't
want to throw the ball too high or
straight up. Once you've practiced enough
with one ball and feel that you can
consistently and accurately throw it
back and forth between your hands in an
arc, then you're ready to give two balls
a shot. With one ball in each hand now
we're going to stand with our hands
shoulder-width apart and waist-high
again with our eyes glancing slightly
above our head. With our starting hand
we'll first toss the ball to our
opposite hand,  and when that first ball
reaches the apex we can then throw the
second ball from our opposite hand up
and under the first one in an arc to our
starting hand. After the second ball is
thrown from our opposite hand we then
need to use that same hand to catch the
first ball that we threw and that's
landing. Then we can get ready to catch
the second ball
our starting hand. As you can see here, I
start with the two balls one in each
hand and first throw with my left hand
and exchange the balls. I then start with
my right hand and do the same exact
thing the opposite way. It can be really
helpful to call the balls out as you
throw "One Two."
Once you get good at it you should
try to practice continuously without
stopping like this. You're not trying to
pass the balls between your hands like
this as a lot of beginners tend to do
You need to get the timing and rhythm
down so that you're not throwing the
ball too early and possibly hitting them
together or even throwing it too late
and causing you to rush and mess up. As
always, make sure that you're staying
within the plane of the window frame and
that you're making accurate consistent
throw is side to side. Otherwise you'll
find yourself making unnecessary
movements which can affect you when you
try to juggle three. Once you feel
confident that you've gotten the hang of
throwing two balls, there's a few
training exercises I'd like to do before
I attempt three balls. While these are
optional, they can further help you
improve your reflexes and hand-eye
coordination and will help you learn 3 a
lot easier. One of the more challenging
exercises is to take two balls in your
starting hand and throw them one by one
across to your opposite hand. Once you
get good at it, the goal is to throw the
first ball across and then the second
one, only to quickly throw the first ball
back to your starting hand before the
second ball lands. Then throw the second
ball after it creating what looks like a
figure eight or snake if done
continuously. Another good exercise is to
learn to juggle two balls in one hand.
To do this you toss the first ball up and
when it hits the peak, throw the second
one after. Then again try to do it
continuously, almost in a circular or
elliptical pattern. While it's also
difficult, if you can master this
juggling three balls in two hands will
become much easier. Also, juggling two
balls in each of your hands
simultaneously is the basis for juggling
four balls, as you saw at the beginning.
To juggle three balls we now need to add
one more ball into the mix and we do
this by placing two balls
our starting hand and one ball in the
opposite hand it doesn't matter which
hand you start with, it's usually
whichever you feel comfortable with, and
I use my left hand. We throw the first
ball from our starting hand and as you
could see here it's represented by the
red line. Just as that ball hits the peak
or apex of its path we then get ready to
throw the next ball, or the one
represented by the blue line, in our
opposite hand. As we throw the second
ball (in blue here) up and under the first
we then have to get ready to catch the
one that's landing (here in red) you can
think of this as an exchange or switch
in that we get rid of the ball that's in
our hand, and after it has gone out, we
then catch the one that's falling or
coming in. Once the second ball (here in
blue) hits its apex we then get ready to
throw the third ball here in green up
and under it just as we've been doing
before. Once again, now that we've thrown
the last ball we have to get ready to
catch the ball that's falling down or
the second ball in blue. This is why
accurate throws are important. Just as
we're lifting up our hand, the blue ball
should kind of be landing right in it.
Now, this is where the cycle repeats
itself. As the last ball is in the air
and Peaks, we now have to begin to throw
the first ball, which is now in our
opposite hand up and under it just as
we've been doing. Demonstrated here I
first place two balls in my starting
hand and one in my opposite hand and I
make the first throw from my starting
hand. I'm going to first try to make
three throws and three catches. Once I've
done that, then I practice with my
opposite hand starting first. When you
feel comfortable and the last ball is in
the air, try and continue with another
for a fourth throw and catch.
Then try five. Stay focused and don't
panic, and try to keep going and once
you've done about twenty catches or so
you can really say you're juggling
Remember, juggling is all about making
accurate and consistent throws and
staying focused once you see the ball in
its peak you need to almost
instinctively know where it's going to
land without looking you'll find when
you practice your hands will almost
start to move on their own to catch them
Once you've learned how to juggle, it's
something you'll never really forget and
you'll definitely want to try with other
objects
(hopefully things that won't break). Thank
you guys so much for watching my
tutorial on How to Juggle. I worked really
hard and I had a lot of fun making it so
I hope you enjoyed. If you did enjoy it,
don't forget to press the thumbs up or
like button down below and also click
the subscribe button and the bell so you
stay notified. Juggling is really fun and
entertaining and you'll definitely
impress others but you need to make sure
you practice practice practice to get it
right let me know what you throw into
the video down in the comment section
below and if you'd like to learn any
cool tricks or things you could do while
juggling I do have some ideas for
upcoming videos and tutorials like paper
planes and other cool stuff like that so
do be sure to click that bell if you want
to stay notified. And have a lot of fun
juggling!